right what's old is new again it's how
we do it here in Vegas right so let's
take you to the Historic Plaza Hotel and
Casino transforming its Main Street
facade Laura negretti's been joining us
there all morning long up down in
between all the good things with the
sneak peek hi Lauren good morning
[Music]
something all over the plaza for their
glittering lights right now of the brand
new Carousel Bar we showed you Oscar's
patio we showed you a little bit about
pink box and the big old Donut entry and
a gaming area that we smoke free that is
separate but now let's talk more about
this Carousel Bar here good morning
Jonathan CEO good morning good morning
nice to be with you nice to meet you as
well so yes Jonathan Josh the CEO of the
plaza let's talk about the Carousel Bar
we are under yeah so this is the
centerpiece of our reimagination of Main
Street this is a sensory overload blog
you're sitting here on this look iconic
location on One Main Street underneath
these light bulbs 8 000 light bulbs and
you've just got a lot of things going on
here so we got well we consider the
centerpiece which is our neon showgirl
we got a seven foot martini glass that
will be rotating we got a deck of cards
an iconic Ace King then we've got the
horses the Vintage parasol horses will
be moving up and down and so that's kind
of the parasol elements but then we
added a few things we have the first of
its kind outdoor video poker machines so
you can sit here having great drinks fun
bartenders I'm Under The Lights playing
video poker I didn't realize it but it's
the first in the state that's Outdoors
video poker and uh and then concluding
is just great dreams we have fun drinks
amazing cocktails great beer product
it's just an over uh overload of sensory
fun a lot of toys that come back June
10th grand opening and about the horses
real quick though it looks tempting you
cannot get on we want to make sure we
say that yeah
[Music]
but this rotating part will be this will
be rotating here yeah that'll be
rotating over there Martini class we
have rotating elements so there's a lot
of movement going on there's a lot of
movement little optical illusion but uh
no boarding the uh the ponies there but
they are vintage as well so yes a lot to
look forward to here
um any other thing to say about this why
people should come on out so yeah come
down come check it out this is uh this
is Downtown Las Vegas it's fun there's a
lot going on so we welcome everyone down
here come check out the bar pink box
donuts and the new smoke-free casino and
Oscar's patio we're looking forward to
having these newer Outlets open thank
you for showing it off this morning
little sneak peek here before that June
10th date for now live at the Plaza
Hotel Laura Negrete eight news now back
to you guys no getting on the carousel
horses John duly noted I know it's
Temptation it's gonna be tempting for a
lot of folks thank you Lauren appreciate
it